well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author christina
patterson and the columnist at the
article ali mirage great to see both of
you as ever though we'll start with the
front pages and the observer focusing on
the prime minister's deepening twin
political crises amid pressure on covert
deals and the row over so-called tory
sleeves reaching new heights
the sunday times is reporting on an
investigation into the conservative
party offering seats in the house of
lords to multi-millionaire donors who
have given large sums to the party
study express leads with an exclusive on
the foreign secretary liz truss's vision
for britain as it declares it's time to
deliver jobs of the future
people power is essential because
politicians just talk and do nothing
reads the scotland on sunday as cop 26
climate protests take place in glasgow
and around the world
the telegraph has seen leaked papers
which show that ministers are prepared
to walk away from major eu research
programs if brussels plays hardball over
the northern ireland borders protocol
and the mail leading with an exclusive
as they say that ministers plan on
bringing back tests and quarantine for
those who refuse to take the booster jab
why every mom should get jab headlines
the sunday people with a story about a
baby girl whose mum has died from covet
just as she was born
the mirror leading with a nurse who
claims to have had a relationship with
david fuller the man who abused corpses
while working in a morgue
while the star on sunday has a story
about strictly come dancing star
aj adodu and his new partner on the show
so christina patterson and ali mirage
are here um quite a mix of headlines has
to be said um but ali talk us through
the observer first of all with the
continuing repercussions of that vote in
in parliament last week in the
subsequent resignation of owen patterson
well yes anna this is uh this uh debacle
continues with the observer now
reporting that
the organizations that owen patterson
was
lobbying for actually secured up to
500 million pounds worth of contracts
government contracts so this story
rumbles on and it's a very very sorry
saga for the government and particularly
the prime minister here to have got
himself into
this is uh people will remember back in
the mid 1990s the the cash for questions
saga they'll also remember the the cash
for peerages saga under tony blair so
governments of various stripes have got
themselves into trouble on this but this
is beginning to
now
the government has to be careful about
having this whiff around it of just
making up the rules as it wishes john
major was very vociferous earlier today
saying that the government is
in certain essences politically corrupt
uh and uh was being very very strong on
this obviously he's a remainer doesn't
like the government because they're
brexiteers but you also have to go back
to the fact that jonathan jones the
government uh head of the legal service
uh resigned in 2020 over the fact that
the government was going to ride
roughshod over the withdrawal agreement
and you had alex allen the adviser on
the ministerial code resigned on the
back of the prime minister ignoring his
recommendations over bullying uh
obligations in relation to pretty patel
so the government's got form on this and
the prime minister needs to get a grip
uh because if you're a backbencher in
the tory party right now you'll be
scratching your head wondering why you
would go and back for the government
again when you're going to have your
legs cut from underneath you within 24
hours when they throw you under the bus
yes i mean certainly sir john major
calling the the whole episode shameful
uh you know other uh leader writing
pieces suggesting the pillars of
democracy being chipped away and yet
christopher hope from the uh daily
telegraph saying actually the government
was trying to do the right thing here
first of all giving mps um
a right of reply effectively and there
was a lot of sympathy for mr patterson
obviously what after what happened to
his his wife the two therefore conflated
together so wherever your sympathies lie
um where does it leave both um the
question marks now over the government
and what they do about this vote that
they've had they need to unpick or do
they christina
well i think the fact that i mean they
they are certainly in a pickle and it's
much more than a pickle actually i'm
sure anybody would have sympathy with
someone whose wife has committed suicide
that's an absolute tragedy and anyone's
heart would go out to owen patterson or
anyone in that situation i think
unfortunately the maybe it's the grief
the most charitable light one can cast
on this is that the grief has
overshadowed his judgment because he was
found to have committed egregious was
the word used in the report egregious uh
breaches of the of the code there is
very little question the evidence is
very damning and um
you know
what's not clear is whether they were
just wanting to get owen patterson off
the hook or if they were actually
wanting to overhaul the whole system
possibly it has been argued because
boris johnson knows that he will face is
likely to face further investigations
over curtin gate
and gold wallpaper gate and all the
other gates that involve unbelievably
expensive and dubiously funded interior
decor at downing street and maybe he was
trying to get
you know make sure that he didn't get a
harsh judgment on that we don't know
what we do know
is that the word corruption and sleaze
has been used extensively this week and
i think i was probably one of many many
people who felt that john mage's
interview this morning was quite
cathartic i went to bed profoundly
depressed the other night when
parliament had voted to abolish the
rulemakers and and decide they were
going to make the rules themselves that
was a real nadir even in a country that
has seen a lot of nadirs in recent years
and to have a formatory prime minister
who himself knows a thing or two about
sleaze and who started the nolan
committee and the nolan principles of
public life as a result of that to hear
his words talking about the corruption
of this government it was some relief
because i think some of us feel we've
been going mad in the last few years
yeah and certainly many people pointing
out that sir john major is no fan of
boris johnson or anything that he has
achieved namely brexit of course so
that's been certainly a part of the mood
music after that interview today um
let's move on to the sunday time shall
we a new tori sleazer hours donors who
pay three million pounds get seats in
the house of lords well we've had a
statement from the conservative party
but um you know tell us about this story
because you know it's not the first time
it has been suggested that this might be
what
happens well i'm surprised it's news
anna
i i'm really surprised that it's news i
mean
parties of all political persuasions for
a long time have been accused of
doling out uh peerages to people who
give cash you've got a situation at the
moment where lord fowler the speaker of
the house of lords has been pleading
with successive prime ministers to limit
the number of people going into the
upper chamber there are now over 800
peers if vladimir putin was stuffing his
the duma with his cronies we'll be
screaming blue murder this is meant to
be the mother of all parliaments and we
have a situation here where
mates of the prime minister successive
prime ministers go back goes back to
labor as well in 0607 there was a police
investigation into the labour party on
their part also um supposedly doling out
cash for peerages so this is not just a
conservative party issue you've got a
situation where you can end up in the
legislature for life by giving money uh
to the party look if you want to reward
political uh donors there's an honor
system to do that there are other ways
of doing it you don't have to give them
a seat in legislature for life and
frankly in its current form i think the
lord's is becoming increasingly
untenable it plays a very important
function in our democracy the house of
lords it's good that they're not elected
but in its present form it's really
coming into distribute and becoming a
bit of a joke so this is a long-running
saga i think it needs to be looked at
thoroughly and it's something that
affects all parties and needs to be
addressed yeah i mean you've picked on
this the article or the paragraph rather
in the santa terms article that i
noticed which is the alleged use of
seeds in the lords as an arm of party
fundraising is particularly
controversial because unlike other
honors like knighthoods peers fulfill an
important role in the legislative
process as a check and balance for new
laws so as you say it has implications
uh the story then that uh the
conservative party was systematically
offering seats in the lords to a select
group of multi-millionaire donors who
pay more than 3 million to the party 3
million pounds
they have issued the statement to us
tonight we do not believe that
successful business people and
philanthropists who contribute to
political causes and parties should be
disqualified from sitting in the
legislature so that's that i want to
very quickly if you don't mind christina
go to
the protests we've seen in glasgow and
elsewhere today um as uh negotiators um
hardly head back for week two after a
day of rest on sunday at cop26 climate
conference um it's been fascinating
hasn't it the people power on the
streets um are they still
as relevant as the money men inside who
are
seeking out
means of investing now in renewable
energy do you think
well i think they have helped to shift
the dial i i'm not a fan of extinction
rebellion i don't like their methods i
don't like the fact that for example
some of their protests have involved
stopping cleaners in the east end
getting to work by uh you know leaping
on tube trains and things like that but
it but you know without these global
protests we wouldn't be where we are now
and people like boris johnson would not
have had their damascene conversion from
severe climatic skepticism to
apparently a huge enthusiasm for action
but not obviously enough action to stop
him leaping straight on a private jet to
get back to a lovely dinner at the
garrett club with charles moore so um
you know
what we need is for people to actually
do what they say they will do and not be
hypocrites then it would be lovely if
our government could perhaps set an
example on that front rather than you
know still jetting around the world i
think boris johnson was on a private jet
just a a couple of weeks ago in fact
possibly last week i think he's on
private jets most weak actually and
given that there are generally seats
available on other flights it doesn't
seem like you know a great look but but
broadly speaking there have been moves
on deforestation which could be very
significant the very fact that india has
committed to to
net zero by 2070 is huge obviously
that's a long way away but it's much
better than that might have been
expected so that there is some good news
here and now we need uh we need to take
the action which will be uncomfortable
and difficult for many many people and
expensive is one of the key points so
you know today
i think yesterday the governor of the
bank of england was saying gas is going
to go up partly because of the cutting
back on fossil fuels and you know it's
all very well to say i'm in favor of
action but when it hits your wallet
that's often a different matter